let's jump to this first story something
interesting to kick off this greater
conversation The Daily Mail reports more
than half of Democrats and Republicans
believe America will cease to exist as a
democracy according to a new poll they
also go on to say the poll found the
majority of Republicans 52 percent say
that it's likely there will be a civil
war in the U.S in their lifetime while
half of Independence 50 and a plurality
of Democrats 46 percent agree the poll
surveyed
1541 adults and was conducted from June
10th on uh from June 10th the day of the
healing uh hearing the January 6 hearing
until June 13th it also found Americans
have largely given up on one another
so before the show you know we we
normally we would do is we'd pull up
like the biggest most relevant story and
issues around it and uh we decided we'd
do something inverted and we would talk
with Dennis Prager about what's going on
why people are experiencing experiencing
this first from your point of view and
then have that actually lead into the
news stories as opposed to the way
around so
this is not the first poll we've seen
where people think civil war is coming
we also had a poll that came out or I
should say a survey that came out from
the splc whether you trust them or not
I'm not a big fan but it showed that the
younger generation is more likely to
support political assassination and
Revolution my view is once the older
generation ages out as it were either
leaves the political uh the political
fight altogether or passes on the next
Generations are going to be increasingly
more prone to violence which ultimately
will lead to Civil War or violence I'm
curious as to your thoughts why people
why you think people feel this way or
what do you think has happened that's
causing it
so let me give you an example when and I
don't know how this registers with you
uh because I remember when I was a kid
and I would hear older people say you
know when I was a kid
and I don't remember how I reacted
either I reacted oh I'm very curious to
know what it was like when you were a
kid or EG I've heard that before having
but I'll take that risk when I was a kid
there was one truly given in this
country you could say whatever you
wanted and I remember it because I would
play I grew up in Brooklyn New York and
we play stickball I have no idea if you
even know what stickball is tell me no
come on
what stick ball oh yeah call the
baseball
no I'm sorry they didn't call it
baseball
well of course it was baseball but it
was called stickball because you played
with a sticky we didn't have a bat in
the street we had a and it was a rubber
ball what neighborhood in Brooklyn uh
Flatbush anyway where the Brooklyn
Dodgers were so anyway uh this is what
would happen some kid would start
screaming at another kid and the other
kid would go oh shut up and then that
kid would say uh I could say whatever I
want this is America that was a common
uh rebuttal to anybody who said shut up
we said that when we were kids okay so
grape even better so that's even better
all right uh that is that is no longer
said by kids uh you could say whatever
you want this is America has been
Shattered by the left and I just want to
make something clear because I'll use
the term left fair fair number of times
I don't believe that left and liberal
are the same I have 32 differences in
one column differences between left and
liberal people could easily look it up
uh Dennis pretty good differences
between left the liberal I did a Prager
you video on it in five minutes I'll
just give you one example liberals
believe in racial integration and left
this belief in racial segregation agreed
okay there's a there's an all black dorm
at Columbia where I went there's an
all-black graduation at Columbia where I
went uh that uh there are only two
groups who support all black dorms uh
leftists and the Ku Klux Klan just for
the record it's really important that
people understand liberals don't support
it and conservatives don't support it so
uh the the ascendance of the left is The
Descent of of all these freedoms and
that that is the root of it if they
allowed us to be heard
we we would not be confronting the
possibility of Civil War we would change
so many minds but they they make it
almost impossible for us to be heard and
that that is the great battle that is
why what what the what Google YouTube uh
Twitter Etc what they have done is is so
injurious to the society it's a
revolution
their their their goal as it was
explained to me is
minimize the right just enough not to
cause a splash but to make them
ineffective in politics so you censor
enough people so that the conversation
will be 60 percent left and 40 percent
right and then what happens is you give
it time and over time the right loses
the argument because they've they've got
no foot in the battle in the battlefield
and I'll give you another interesting
thing that people don't reflect on
we ache to have them on our shows we
ache to debate them but they won't
debate us and they won't come on our
shows and they want us have us on their
shows I have offered tens of thousands
of dollars to any left-wing columnist on
the New York Times to debate me anywhere
they want they could choose the
moderator they could choose the audience
and serious money
uh uh and that's 99 of the New York
Times columnists Are leftists maybe
there are three that are not none left
uh but they would never do it I ache to
debate them
I would I would raise a hundred thousand
dollars probably I could probably raise
that to have tanahisi Coates or Ibrahim
X candy debate Larry Elder okay it would
end the career of tanahisi coats or
Ibrahim to know that they would be
regarded as the moral and intellectual
frauds that they are Larry would wipe
the floor with them uh uh uh I could
give you five black intellectuals who
would wipe the floor with them that's
the whole that's that's the key to their
success is not enabling us to have an
audience but you see it seems that they
target what we would refer to as NPCs
are you familiar with the term no
non-player characters people who don't
take an active role and don't care and
just say tell me what to believe and
tell me how to fit in so you take a look
at I'll give you the example I love to
give we can start with the Trayvon
Martin story which was not true hands up
don't shoot that was not true uh Ahmed
aubry's story that was not true
russiagate Ukraine gate jussie Smollett
because I think president said they were
good Nazis that there were fine Nazis
the launching of Joe Biden's campaign
not true and so when they come out and
they say we're the good guys trust us
don't listen to them and we come out and
we say please listen to everything they
have to say and then have a conversation
with us the people who are interested in
saying I want to know for myself they'll
come and take a look and watch the video
and say oh okay Dennis is clearly right
on those issues they'll the people who
don't want to do that say look man I
just want to fit in I'm going to do
whatever they tell me I think what we're
seeing now is
largely the separation is I described
this four years ago I called it the
uninitiated and the politically
Discerning people who will look at a
story and say is that true let me check
and the people who say I don't know it's
probably True Media said it those people
just blindly follow The Narrative of the
establishment media they believe fake
news every single time I should say the
overwhelming majority of them just
believe whatever the TV says even though
it's proven wrong over and over again
and then you have the other side which
includes lip traditional liberals
Libertarians moderates conservatives
those are all right-wing what I I
facetiously say what makes you right
wing is knowing facts reality as a
conservative bias Stephen Colbert he
said that line I'm sure you're familiar
with reality is a liberal bias you know
20 or so years ago but now the issue is
if someone comes out and says oh did you
know that Hunter Biden was on the board
of barisma and was receiving 83 000 a
month and that Joe Biden intervened with
the quid pro quo to withhold U.S
guaranteed Aid to the government unless
the government did him a favor to stop
and to fire this prosecutor just so
happened the prosecutor was
investigating the company where his son
worked if you say that you're right wing
regardless of your politics so if you
know the facts you're right wing
a guy came over to me at an airport
right before the lockdowns by the way I
I hope you'll all adopt this I never say
before covid I say before lockdowns yeah
covet is not the issue it was the
reaction the destruction was the
lockdowns anyway so about a few months
before the lockdowns at Philadelphia
Airport I recall well
the guy comes over to me and I thank God
people come over to me at every airport
except Boston interestingly I don't have
any fans in Boston but anyway guy comes
over to me and and I'm a heterosexual
guy so it's not often that I think well
this guy's really good looking this guy
was really good looking I'm six foot
four not as good looking as this guy
this guy was six foot four comes over
with a minimal accent minimal and tells
me oh I really love your work and I go
where are you from he goes Norway I said
oh you watch prageru in Norway oh yeah
all the time I go really you're you're a
Norwegian conservative and he said to me
this was priceless apropos what you just
said and he said
I I don't know if I'm conservative I
just follow logic and I said then you're
conservative that's how it goes these
days that's how it goes let me give a
to to reiterate my point
um here's a guy who just sees you tell
the fact and says interesting and you
would be in the United States that's
conservative
that's right yeah yeah that's exactly it
uh I I would like to know what position
I hold that is not directed by morality
and logic I'd like to know one position
that I hold and I would probably drop it
if if logic and morality do not dictate
that position I hereby announce I will
drop it I'll tell you we had a we had a
fun time we had a progressive on the
show a couple weeks ago and it was uh
Sheamus Coughlin Freedom Tunes who's a
CR he's a Catholic conservative uh
pro-life there's me which I guess uh
disaffected liberal post-liberal
whatever they call it and um you know
moderately pro-choice and then this
Progressive who was pro-abortion up to
the point of birth or maybe Beyond and
it was funny because Sheamus backed off
he was just like he let me you know and
this guy have this discussion and then
eventually I said to him I was like this
is the crazy thing you know I asked him
do you believe abortion should be uh the
woman's Choice up to the point of birth
or it should be allowed legal and he
said woman's choice and I was like the
woman is about to give birth to a maybe
at nine month gestation and the baby can
be terminated killed ripped out and he
goes woman's choice and I'm like okay
well I come from a traditional liberal
background where we're like you know
maybe after the fetus is viable you just
save it you don't have to kill it right
and then I was like but isn't it strange
that I am a pro-choice liberal and
you're calling me right wing and you're
arguing for abortion to the point of
birth how is that the liberal position
how is how is that we're having this
argument and the actual conservative
over here is keeping his mouth shut it's
just the whole as you mentioned with the
left and liberal being different yeah
you got to be careful with labels
relying too much on labels and what they
mean to you because they might mean
something different to someone else but
it's the facts and beliefs that are
really important well that's why it's
important to Define as I did I I I as I
said I have an article with 32
distinctions and and the the race one is
one of the biggest we believe in
integrate we believe we do believe
liberals I was raised I'm a Jew from New
York by definition a liberal and I was
raised that Ray
blind is the moral ideal you don't see a
person's race you see their character
you see their personality you see their
brains you see everything and and so I I
today race is determinative which is
mind-boggling because I ask left this
one question if you know a person is
black tell me one other thing you know
about them
and they can't name a thing do you know
whether they're kind or despicable do
you know whether they're honest or
crooked do you know whether they are
interesting or boring do you know
whether they are uh liberal or
conservative you know nothing when you
know someone's skin color you can tell
more about a person by their shoes than
you can by their race that's that's
perfectly said yeah thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this Channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time